I got all of you
Demi's girlfriend Christian joins
paradise I came all the way down here to
pursue and Showdown me my level of
commitment after a serious conversation
with Chris Harrison and feeling torn
over her budding romance with Derrick
one of them deserves to have all of me
better I'm scared that I'm not gonna
make the right choices Chris surprised
Demi by bringing Christian to paradise
how did things go for you paradise is
amazing it was so fine so emotional but
ultimately all worth it
very very good Derrick took the blow
like a true gentleman it's just what my
heart feels okay and the other castmates
reactions were more than supportive to
say the least to let love be whatever
way is any judgments or any expectations
like that's that's true life we'll have
to stay tuned to see how Derek's journey
to find love plays out but Demi and
Christian were able to reconcile as
she's planning to stay in paradise how
serious two things get for you in
paradise you know you'll have to watch
and see et spoke with Chris Harrison
earlier this month where he opened up
about bachelor in paradise his decision
to have their relationship play out on
the show I'm really proud as a host a
producer and just as a man and a father
of two of how we handled it and and at
the end of the day I always tell the
producers and most of them are younger
than I am all you can do is make the
best decision at the time and handle it
the best way you feel like you can and I
feel like we did it's sensitive subject
it shouldn't be and we're trying to kind
of rip that band-aid off but it is and
it's still it it's very you know it's
gonna be taboo and I'm not so naive as
to think it's all gonna be positive the
fact that we're doing this and we're
diving into this I'm proud of Demi I'm
proud of our producers I'm proud of the
way we handled it I think it's great
and it's time it's it's more than time
but I'm glad that we've done it in the
right way very organically allowing it
to happen naturally demi had already
said she's gotten some heat already
online for it so do you imagine that's
what you're saying there will be more of
that backlash from stumpy yeah I've
talked to Demi you know I talked to her
after all this is over and you know she
was crying we were all crying we're
hugging and and we you know we we were
very careful of how we handled this
whole thing and I think we did a great
job but I told everybody because ever we
were we're in our little cocoon and
everybody was you know I was very
celebratory and very happy and I said
just know that there's gonna be negative
that comes with this from within that
community and in from without and that's
that'll be the interesting thing is
within that community we're gonna get
backlash and I'm prepared for that
that's that's just the world we live in
with social media everything else you
didn't handle it right you didn't do it
the right way you didn't do it their way
everyone's gonna have their spin on it
their perspective and how they want to
see it this is how we did it there's how
we portrayed it and I will stand behind
it there's still a beautiful future
and happiness is enough